wir wollen jetzt noch einmal auf die
geschehnisse vom 6 januar schauen und
zwar auf den sturm auf das us capitol
mittlerweile sind mindestens fünf
menschen dabei gestorben
und jetzt das neueste opfer das bekannt
geworden ist ist officer brian die
technik der polizist war selber im
dienst und soll dann von einem der
radikalen demonstranten mit einem
feuerlöscher erschlagen worden seien
erst später im krankenhaus verstorben
die mordkommission ermittelt nun selber
zu den weiteren opfern gehören ashley
bei betty die 35 jährige wurde von der
polizei erschossen der polizist
mittlerweile suspendiert auch dort läuft
jetzt ein ermittlungsverfahren
kevin grießen der 55 jährige aus alabama
erlitt einen herzinfarkt bei ihm soll
bereits zuvor bluthochdruck
diagnostiziert worden sein es ist noch
nicht klar bei auch teil des
gewalttätigen mobs war genau so steht es
um benjamin philips auch bei dem 50
jährigen ist das noch nicht klar
er ist also weniger und starb an einem
schlaganfall der programmierer war
vorher mit einem dutzend anderer tram
fans aus pennsylvania nach washington
gereist das fünfte todesopfer roseanne
bauland 34 jahre alt aus georgia
sie soll im capitol von der menge
totgetrampelt worden sein das sagte ihre
familie jetzt der britischen polizisten
soll noch versucht haben sie
wiederzubeleben
das soweit also die opfer des sturms auf
das kapitol und genau deswegen wegen
dieser schrecklichen folgen und wegen
einem bildern die wir gesehen haben ist
jetzt auch das fbi damit beschäftigt
diesen fall weiter aufzuklären max zeigt
ihnen jetzt einmal was genau da die
ermittlungen nun sind genau nele hat es
gesagt die legendäre bundesbehörde fbi
dort wird ermittelt und zwar gegen 41
männer und frauen die das kapitel
gestürmt haben wir zeigen ihnen hier auf
unserem screen das offizielle
fahndungsplakat mehrere davon gibt es
mit denen nun in den usa nach diesen
menschen gefahndet wird wir wollen ihnen
einmal im detail zeigen was für menschen
sind das und wie wird nach ihnen gesucht
was uns aufgefallen ist ist zb hier
denn foto nummer vier mit welcher ruhe
die menschen dort offenbar durch das
kapitel gezogen sind ja hatte man sogar
zeit am ende noch self auszumachen zu
grinsen in aller ruhe und nee da hat es
eingangs der sendung gesagt einige von
ihnen tragen auch keine maske der herr
hier auch keine sonnenbrille das macht
es vermutlich am ende auch relativ
einfach ihn zu identifizieren
als zweites beispiel wollen wir ihnen
zeigen da gibt es um diese frau hier
machst du noch ein bisschen größer was
zu erkennen ist wir hatten es in unserer
sondersendung mehrfach thematisiert
diese protest dieser protestzug dieser
dieser mob hat es eben auch in die büros
der abgeordneten geschafft und hier
sehen wir also eine junge frau auf ihrem
auf ihrem kopf hat sie diese legendäre
keep america great erkennen also die
base cap von donald trump auf und sie
hat es in ein büro einer abgeordneten
geschafft geht dort durchs telefonbuch
guckt sich das in ruhe an wertet
vielleicht auch aus die telefonnummern
schreibt sie sich mit ein absoluter
albtraum für die sicherheitsbehörden
wir wollen die noch ein anderes beispiel
zeigen das haben wir hier ein mensch der
sich besonders ungeschickt verhalten hat
kann man sagen der hat nämlich beim
sturm auf das us capitol seinen arbeits
war ausweis dabei gehabt und ist damit
für alle menschen zu identifizieren
gewesen mehrere fotos von
nachrichtenagenturen zeigen ihn und da
hat sich heute auch schon der
arbeitgeber zu wort gemeldet eine
marketingagentur und die haben sich von
diesem mann getrennt und damit erstmal
wieder zurückzunehmen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren